you
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan sockin and now on our
second part of the day we have dr. and
rokunova thank you for coming on Thank
You Alan yes Andre is the founder and
CEO of Silicon Valley Innovation Center
we're be talking about the future of
business where each time about
disrupting education this is gonna be a
lot of fun I'm really excited to have
you you likewise thank you for inviting
me yeah you're always welcome Silicon
Valley Innovation Center I'm so happy to
have met the family they're like
everyone there that's hustling to bring
in people from around the world show
them kind of what Silicon Valley's up to
also learn from them and what they're
doing across the world it's totally my
vibe yeah oh okay well I'm glad to hear
that Alan I started this company about
seven years ago before that I was
working at Stanford University
organizing all kinds of programs working
at the center which was called the
Center for Russian easterbrook and
Eurasian studies originally I am from
Kazakhstan myself which was a part of
the former Soviet Union so it was kind
of natural I guess for me to run a
central like that back at Stanford part
of my responsibilities there was to run
executive education programs that would
involve incoming groups of executives
from all over the world who would come
and learn from the faculty of Stanford
University Stanford was of course a
great place to organize programs like
that but the thing is that now education
is evolving a lot right in different
directions one of the directions was is
actually is trying to learn from the
source and that's where I found an
opportunity to start a new company where
I could connect my clients not just with
the best faculty of the world not just
with professors you know who have lots
of interesting academic knowledge but
not necessarily a lot of practical
knowledge I started a company which
would provide a new type of education
for executives and that would be
education that would be coming out of
but it's technology companies now our
faculty our entrepreneurs our engineers
people who create new businesses entire
Silicon Valley pretty much this is why I
called this company in Silicon Valley
Innovation Center because we still
continue innovating ourselves you know
when we're trying to reinvent what
education at least executive education
is all about but we're also trying to
invent new business models for ourselves
as well and for our partners in Silicon
Valley all the companies that are
hosting our groups yes so there's the
component of executive innovation and
executive education let's let's go to
the journey the the journey that led you
led you to be who you are and how you
got to where you are so were you born in
Kazakhstan as well yes yes so when did
you decide to move around to for
University and for etc yeah
well I was born 46 years ago in
Kazakhstan when it was still a part of
the Soviet Union my ancestors my
mother's parents were polish peasants
who used to live in that part of Poland
which was divided between Hitler and
Stalin when the Second World War started
so my folks were exiled from that part
of Poland which became part of Ukraine
in 1939 to Kazakhstan that's how they
ended up being there it's not like it
was necessarily the best choice for them
to leave but that's how Soviet Union in
many ways operated back then families
polish then yeah yeah my mother's family
is polish you know my father's family
was Ukrainian and they ended up being in
Kazakhstan for different reasons but
that's how you know they found each
other and I was born in Kazakhstan as I
said it was it was not like the best
place to be born to be honest with you
because I was born like in the middle of
nowhere pretty much it was a part of
step block which was a part of a gulag
and then gulag was like a network of
labor camps and concentration camps in
in the Soviet Union it was not like I
was affected by my family was not
affected by by that system but it was a
a place in Kazakhstan where I was born
was not an easy place to live let's put
it this way which gave me a lot of
motivation yes you know to kind of find
something more interesting in life yeah
so I went and I graduated from my first
University in the capital of Kazakhstan
Almaty in 1994 I got my so-called red
diploma which was like a straight A's
diploma there in philosophy and
political science philosophy was
something that I was really always
fascinated about yeah but you know in
mid 90s getting a job as a philosopher
it was it was next impossible of course
so I had to do something more practical
for my life and I decided to continue my
education so I went to Hungary I got
admitted to Central European University
there so I got my master's degree in
economics and transition transition
economics and politics from the Central
European University in Budapest then I
moved to northern England for another
year
Newcastle Newcastle University where I
got another master's degree in
international politics Oh international
economics actually that's what it was it
was in 1996 I almost forgot about this
and then I was admitted to Stanford and
that's how I came to the US and that was
how you know that you wanted to go to
the Stanford area to the Bay Area how
did you know I had a very good friend
back then who I met when I was still a
student in Kazakhstan his name was
Robert Young he was already in his 70s
when he visited Kazakhstan and we kind
of became friends and he was the
graduate of Stanford University and he
was the first guy who I think who told
me about Stanford back then that there
is this great University Andre and you
have to think about you know
lying there all of that and somehow
miraculously he was the guy who found a
fellowship which I applied for when I
was already a student and in Newcastle
and he was travelling somewhere in
Kazakhstan he found in an ad about a
fellowship that was advertised by
Stanford University across all
post-socialist countries it was called
new democracy fellowship it was
organized right by a few Stanford
professors including people like condi
rice she was a Provost at Stanford and
Alyssa rice and Alex Dolan who was one
of the top leading Soviet ologist back
then so they got together they found
some funding to help former students
well back then there was still the
current students so for the eastern from
Eastern Europe to get the top rate
education in the United States so I was
lucky to get you know how to apply for
that fellowship and Bob young a friend
of mine he connected me essentially to
Stanford by sending this fellowship to
me good and you know the rest is history
I was I was I God first then I was so I
got my PhD in 2008 clinical economy
political science strictly speaking but
I also took a lots of courses in the
poop in the con Department and the
business school so my academic field
that I was most interested in was
political economy yeah yeah that's what
I was elated about and for a long while
I was thinking that I'm gonna be a
researcher you know studying how
politics affects the economy and vice
versa across different countries but
then that's a nice rating field it's
it's a you're right that you do canals
how how things move how they're how
they're made and then how they move
across country lines how they get sold
to the different people in those
countries how they're consumed and then
what happens to the good or service
afterward all that stuff is so
interesting well I would say especially
now when you see again I'm not
practicing researcher anymore I don't I
cannot say that I am up to what's
happening in research on these topics
but what we're seeing here right now is
that the boundaries that used to define
our living in the past geographic
boundaries are becoming less important
right and there are new types of
entities that are being created as we
speak you know entities like Facebook
for example you know this is not a
national entity and yet and prepare
permeates many countries right now many
societies in various ways right we just
heard about the scandal that Facebook
has leaked so much mean firm ation
private information for hundreds of what
tens of millions of people right in the
US and that affected the elections in
various ways so things like that of
course are affecting the old ways how
people used to think about political
economy I used to think about their
political identity their economic
well-being all of that and and things
like that are profoundly changing the
way we leave and I and I think what this
happening is that this processes are
accelerating as we speak we are
somewhere on a curve for exponential
growth in many ways so the way how fast
we were moving before is very different
from the way how we how fast we are
right now and tomorrow we will probably
be changing even faster yeah and that's
why what everything that we're
discussing right now about future
business and innovation and education
and all that again has just been
changing so much over this hockey stick
yeah up where do we go
so okay so I mean let's let's touch a
little bit more on the political and the
economics before we get into more SBIC
stuff just realize this is so they're so
interesting what are some of the most
profound things that you learn
in your last couple years before Silicon
Valley Innovation Center when you were
working with within the technology
development in Kazakhstan and within the
Eurasian Studies at Stanford and stuff
and bringing the executives here what
was kind of the political and economic
conversations about how to best and move
forward as the world well Stanford as a
place was of course and still is an
amazing place to be I would say
definitely it's where you can find a lot
of very gifted students being taught by
a lot of very talented professors so I
personally enjoyed my years of being
there I totally I've been there for like
almost like 10 years because it was like
a golden cage it's it's not easy to get
in there but it's even harder to get out
if you have a chance to stay so I kind
of enjoyed being there for quite a while
and part of that of course was it was a
intellectual curiosity yes that you can
satisfy thereby yes hanging around
different people who are thinking about
the future you know who are building you
discovering new facts essentially doing
science you know and being a part of
that process of course was was really
fascinating for me personally I have
always been struggling with the question
of like I said political economy were to
what extent politics effects economic
processes and vice versa
how much politics is a function of
economic developments right so just to
take one question democracy right we
have seen over the let's say over the
last hundred years a huge spread of
democratic values all over the world yes
right a hundred years ago most of the
countries we're not democratic right
they were run by all kinds of you know
kings or authority autocratic regimes
all of that and now when we see what's
been
a trend over this hundred years was a
spread of democracies
now you start I always wanted to answer
this question who is it coincidental
that that growth in democratic values
has always kind of been closely matched
with the economic development of those
countries as well could you sustain a
democracy in a poor country or could you
have a very rich society that would not
want to be democratic there's a good
amount of literature on the North Korea
South Korea right inclusive versus
exclusive economy and what it does and
political economy what that does to the
country
B&C right now right difference between
South Korea success in the world and
North Korea's not success yeah that's
right world so so that I would say so
that democracy has been but to what
extent has it been a major impact with
with economic success right that that's
exactly a question right good question
um we know from our history that well
even from the current state of affairs
that there are some rich countries that
are not democratic like I just visited
Singapore for example you know it's a
it's a pretty rich country or we just
had a few clients who came to visit us
from Saudi Arabia and that's you know
Kingdom with its own culture which is
not very democratic let's put it this
way even though they are changing as
well yeah pretty quickly right now and
then you get other examples on the other
side of the spectrum countries like
India right it's not a very yet very
wealthy country right if you look at the
per capita per capita income and yet
they are quite Democratic right so the
relationship between wealth and the
adoption of democratic institutions is
not straightforward right you don't get
yeah it going in the same way
both of them but the general trend in my
opinion well that's I guess my
conviction that I hold is that in order
to sustain the the spread of genuine
democratic values you need to give
enough economic freedoms to people as
well this is one day when you get a very
robust healthy middle class those people
who really care about their freedoms and
they use those freedoms to continue
developing their wealth
like for example freedom of expression
it's a very important freedom that helps
people to predict and kind of to think
about the future right when they can
understand what politicians are talking
about or what you could say against the
politicians you can plan your economic
you can do better economic planning for
your life for your family and and this
is when I think political freedoms and
economic freedoms in economic
development go hand in hand you know
when you have a very robust a middle
class that needs it political freedoms
in order to sustain its economic growth
and when you get those two things
diverge from each other that's when
there is a danger that some societies
can become increasingly autocratic we're
gonna go down a really good path with
that we'll get to it at the very end I'm
excited to hear your thoughts it's so
good that you're pulled political and
economic expertise and background to
hear some of your thoughts on it at the
end will be really really important and
even now to be able to for the world to
care more about politics and economics
and how that impacts our world that's
another whole hour-long conversation
they're us for us to have now okay
you just had Saudi Arabia come to
Silicon Valley Innovation Center
you learned a lot from what they were
bringing to you and you were teaching
them a lot maybe tell us about kind of
like walk us through what that
experience is like for you and for them
what do you how do you help them how do
they help you why do they even come out
here and ride around with you well that
particular client were actually they
visited us a few months ago without
naming and names here it was one of the
company's major companies from Saudi
Arabia that was involved in distributing
major car brands and they wanted to they
came to Silicon Valley to understand
what's going on with that particular
vertical market with cars right the the
entire industry of transportation is now
being reshaped so quickly that we get
you know self-driving cars showing up on
the market right you get electric cars
and all these trends are affecting
profoundly the entire industry including
those players who are distributing cars
and they want to understand what's going
to happen to them just to give you one
example of how this new technology
trends can play out specifically in in
auto markets if you get self-driving
cars being very popular among the young
people as a way of you know driving
instead of you know using a ride
essentially not driving themselves you
can end up getting the number of car
cars being owned reduced dramatically
right so that's already been happening
with companies like uber or was the
other one that I'm using uber Muslim but
lyft of course yes both of those cars
are providing pretty reliable services
right now for us to be to be driven
anywhere
so there's especially in a place like
San Francisco you don't need to have a
car anymore so we do with the parking
meters on the street parking garages how
does that impact the economy when you
own an autonomous car design then your
autonomous
goes and makes you money what's driving
that cycle around it yeah there are so
many different scenarios right that
might affect let's say the car
dealerships that these guys were in as a
business in different ways you know
maybe the amount of cars in the future
will be dramatically reduced yes as a
result of these new technologies I guess
we might end up getting new types of a
transportation like flying car yeah
correct right so these guys have come in
order to understand how far away are we
from those futuristic things you start
happening in our life when should they
start changing up their business yes
when should they start partnering with
more and more of the AI and electrical
vehicles yes these in that kind
absolutely Silicon Valley is one of
those amazing places where you can come
and you don't really have to go anywhere
else
to understand pretty much almost like
everything from across different
technology trends yes that can affect
the future of your industry this is what
makes people very attracted to this
place because we're almost like
manufacturing magic here yeah I mean
those people who work in these companies
I don't I shouldn't take any ownership
for I don't creating magic myself but at
least what we do to certain excuse ed a
little though
yes I think you feel I think I sure I
think we should as well we do have very
little bit to our part right yeah and
you can connect the people that come
from Saudi Arabia to somebody that does
actually to companies that do build
electrical cars and the artificial
intelligences that drivers absolutely so
and they want to be connected to them be
able to know from the source like yours
exactly and it actually benefits both
sides you know it benefits the
established industries those who want to
understand what's going on but it also
Bennett's the benefits the local
startups because they are the ones who
are trying to get attention to their
inventions right they're looking for the
markets they're trying to reach to
customers and we're the ones who are
bringing those customers but they're
drawn the world yes their door yeah so
okay so you
you mentioned you know the future of
business being potentially tell me if
this is right is the future of business
something along the lines of I'm looking
at my business within the industry and I
see you know a technology that's
currently being disruptive in my
industry so I need to do things like
prepare myself with my business and my
strategy by going and making lots of
relationships with that technology that
is disrupting that business so my
business can be a leader in the future
yes well first you have to understand
what's going on right in order to make
any intelligent decisions about the
future course you have to understand
where you are right now right and what
kind of technologies are coming to
disrupt the business your industry your
business potentially and how you should
build your strategy in anticipation of
those changes right so the first stage
has always to be like an exploratory
stage where you have to as a business
owner or maybe an executive or working
for a large company you have to
understand what you don't know and when
we don't know what we don't know right
and that's what is important to
understand that the limits of our
knowledge on these new technologies that
are being created as we speak
coming to Silicon Valley allows you to
learn what you don't know right to
extend your horizons in in your
knowledge of different technologies but
also understand how new startups are
taking those technologies and turning
them into the new disruptive business
models those business models that might
be quite superior to what you might have
and that's where the threat of
disruption might be coming from right
new businesses that have a potential to
steal all your customers right because
they are doing something way better than
you do and if you recognize that threat
that's when you should start thinking
about transforming your business
you know in thinking about different
ways how you could protect yourself
against that disruption by also you know
improving your products you know
perfecting your services and perhaps
even creating those startups yourself as
well it's a large company and that's
what we have seen many large businesses
have been trying to do you know setting
up new digital entities yeah that would
be almost like self disruptive for them
and yet it they would help them these
entities to preserve their position on
the market instead of just passively
observing the way how you're getting
disrupted by others you better take your
risks and maybe set up your own startup
so that's one misname one car company
that doesn't have an autonomous division
exactly that you're exactly right yes so
all of them are recognizing now that
autonomous cars you know they will
define the future whether they like it
or not and not exactly a you're not just
out on amidst cars but also electric
cars yes I think many larger saleem
engines over yeah yep yeah whether you
like it or not for multiple reasons yes
right not just for one room not for just
environment yes yes that's right
so this is what's happening and it's
great to be in the middle of it yeah
there's and again of this just a very
short story is that the reason why I
came here was because so many
entrepreneurs were coming from Silicon
Valley to the business school in the
University of Minnesota and just coming
up to them with this lease lists of
ideas how do I build these into the
world right move to where everyone's
doing it kid go do it
there wherever I was doing it and so
that was the big like aha I do I will
and I did and it's been the best
decision of my life I get to I saw
myself with all these brilliant people
and and there's more billion people
around the world but this is just this
hub like you said people get to come
here they get to okay let's a little bit
more about the future of business okay
so we're in the middle of Silicon Valley
Silicon Valley has all
different trends that are disrupting
business the your the future of
businesses to be able to go and analyze
how these trends are disrupting business
and to apply them to these new
technologies to how you do your own
business so that way you don't get left
behind yourself that's right and so as I
do that everyone seems to be saying you
know data data is the new oil and
blockchain is the new security and
cryptography and and then so everyone's
you know overhyping so many of these
different areas and maybe what are some
what are some valuable cuz it's
different for every business yeah it's
different for every business what's
disrupting it but what are kind of some
of the hot-button we talked about
autonomous cars would have been some of
the other hot-button topics that people
are coming in and wanting to learn about
what they think is revolutionizing their
world and potentially their business so
that's why they're here learning about
it
well here's what we have seen with our
clients first of all when you live in
Silicon Valley you kind of live inside
of this bubble right it's the bubble
that continues to perpetuate itself not
just in terms of devaluations of the
companies but also the way how advanced
people are in thinking about new
technologies you know whoever blockchain
yeah like you know cryptocurrencies
everybody's obsessed now about that
you know I cos all of this but when you
go outside of this bubble you know just
you know go like 500 miles away from
Silicon Valley you still find most
companies are conducting their business
the way they did it like 20 30 years of
Acts machine yeah exactly so so once
once you move away from from Silicon
Valley you start discovering that most
businesses are only now discovering for
themselves how to digitally change
themselves in in some very basic ways
like I have hosted some companies that
were selling information and yet they
were not digital themselves at all which
is kind of
contradiction in terms right selling
information and yet not being a digital
company but that's how they are because
they were set up they were founded like
30 40 years ago when information was
already important very important but yet
it was not like really digitized so
these companies are now trying to catch
up with some something very basic for
Silicon Valley is how to digitize your
assets if you have any information
assets yeah so some basic trends like
that are very important you're
established businesses right how to
protect yourself against disruption in
the cyberspace as well right now that
you've got your physical assets exposed
to cybercrime you have to find the ways
how to stay protected against those
intrusions right and this is where I
think we're gonna see a lot of
innovation happen simply because lots of
businesses are vulnerable still
vulnerable to crypto well to to cyber
attacks and where there's still a lot of
potential for digital transformation but
the more you transform yourself digital
of course you know that's where the
paradox is the more vulnerable
potentially you make yourself do all of
those attacks yeah right so I would say
crypto I'm sorry not crypto but
cybersecurity will be a major trend yeah
of course I keep saying crypto it's
because everybody is talking about
cryptocurrencies nowadays and I think
even though there's a lot of regulatory
is a major part of Cyprus that's already
as well that's that's where they overlap
yeah actually the exactly I think with
cryptocurrencies we're gonna see a lot
of innovation as well you know
blockchain I think it's been overhyped
right now to be honest likewise
but the the real effect of blockchain
will probably happen like ten years from
now maybe even 15 years down the road
but it has a huge potential you know in
sort of creating the technological
platforms
for building trust without having a
third party like a bank or any other
institution that has to verify that
Trust has a profound effect for multiple
industries not just for banking yeah or
financial services generally speaking
definitely but I think it has a profound
impact for multiple vertical markets but
that's gonna happen like in my opinion
like 10 years down the road I don't
think we should expect any other such
successful use cases as cryptocurrency
has been for blockchain so far but even
crypto currency has been overhyped
itself as well so I think we always have
to be careful about about not being too
exuberant about these technologies and
not becoming a part of this bubble right
because if you are investing in these
new technologies or new startups or
maybe new cryptocurrencies you better be
very careful if you don't know what
you're doing Jason Calacanis wrote a
really good post about that it's he did
a really good job addressing that
exactly investing in cryptocurrency
right maybe you touched a little bit
about your your so your most common
program is the corporate innovation
training corporate innovation and
digital transformation yep the corporate
innovation and digital transformation so
and we were just talking about the
importance of getting companies into the
digital space yes and then cyber
security being a really important goo
they go together once you expand into
digital space we need the cyber security
to help us protect ourselves now on the
corporate innovation training I guess we
were also talking about bringing in
different companies and what they get to
experience with like if you're a car
company innovation training with
autonomous vehicles so ok so that's the
main that those are kind of the main
pillars and then kind of some of the
what are coming some of the other kind
of secondary stuff as they come here
they also get partnerships like with the
startup you said and they get a partner
across the world that's very good
important right and then also maybe what
else maybe some of the small summits and
the big sub yes yeah
we do organize all kinds of conferences
or we participate in Coe organizing this
conference is the next one that we're
doing just a week from now is called a
global blockchain forum yep it's one
week now yeah yeah one week from now so
I would encourage anybody who is
watching us live to check it out global
blockchain forum if it's okay that I
advertise course where is it it's going
to be in Santa Clara Convention Santa
Clara Convention the second third of
April on the second thirty yes
so we're going to be bringing a lots of
people over there to discuss exactly
these issues you know how much is being
over hard what kind of new applications
exist for different vertical markets you
know how to invest in these new
cryptocurrencies and to be safe in doing
that you asked me about the what are
their other trends and lessons well one
of the interesting lessons I think for
senior executives at least for those
companies who come to Silicon Valley has
been at least for me how important
startups are becoming for established
markets you when you think about the
past the way how corporate world used to
be organized in the past it was always
dominated by the large conglomerates
they were the ones who were calling
shots in pretty much all industries
right they were the ones who were made
data there was a centralized yes well
they for all kinds of reasons large
sized companies were the ones monopolies
were the ones who were determining the
way how business was done across
different industries what's happening
right now is truly amazing
it's totally revolutionary in my opinion
it's when small companies small startups
are sometimes way too powerful than
those corporations and those
corporations are now being more and more
frequently becoming victims of these
small companies you know disrupting yeah
these large businesses just think about
the most
example toys-r-us just announced that
they're going bankrupt I mean it's it's
a sad news for all the employees the
shareholders and everybody else but I
guess it's kind of logical that retail
is losing so retail physical retail is
now losing to companies like Amazon
which was just a startup another you
know 20 years ago Amazon was a tiny
company 20 years ago now you get Amazon
dominating retail markets right and
totally revolutionizing that you look
across different and that's 20 years I
mean that's that's that's the blink of
an eye yeah yeah but but what's
happening right now
even this blink of an eye is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller yeah
when you look at the time how much time
does it take for a comp for a small
start-up to become a unicorn you see
more and more examples of companies
reaching this billion-dollar valuation
where an air faster and faster and
faster so yeah and then they completely
destroy the hotel market yes destroy the
taxi yeah yes so fast right that's nuts
yes and and these are just a few
examples of how startups when they're
equipped with right people and right
technologies can become this
revolutionary force against big
established companies all over the world
yeah so this is probably one of the kind
of the most shocking examples for me of
how innovation works how disruptive
innovation I guess works yeah nowadays
and we see more and more and more of
those startups coming to the markets to
redefine what those markets are all
about disruptive innovation yeah yeah
because it's it's no longer just about
and the Peter Thiel is so good at
explaining this but it's no longer about
just disrupting some small part of some
small market if you want competition go
start a restaurant or a bar but if you
really
want to dominate do unicorn become a
monopoly you find that thing that why is
nobody else building this thing that
everyone would want to have in their
lives this value and then build that
thing and become fanatic about building
it you recruit other brilliant people to
help you because they love your vision
they love your emotional connection as
well to them and to their families and
to the business that you're building
with them and then that's how to really
create another one of these unicorn
companies out there I love that
disruptive innovation is something that
is just it flows through the veins of
Silicon Valley right yeah yeah and I
think it's it's a testimony to the power
of four new technologies yep
you know one of the reasons why small
tiny companies sometimes become
infinitely more powerful than the old
huge companies it's because they equip
themselves with the technologies that
have that are way more powerful yep
right then the ones that existed before
so if you if you want to be a true
disruptive force perhaps smaller size
it's on the add its your advantage
rather than your liability as it was in
the past you know in the past when you
were dominated by these large players
for if you were a small company it would
be very hard for you to compete with
them right now small size often is
viewed as an advantage for moving fast
pivoting quickly yes and and then
employing new technologies that
sometimes require a lot of agility you
know so that you don't have to negotiate
its deployment quickly sometimes you
didn't get in trouble with that as well
like Facebook you know I'm coming back
to what I just heard this morning yeah
it's an example yes because Facebook has
been experimenting a lot with data and
they ended up in trouble by giving away
unwittingly lots of information about
its users now they're being pounded for
that but hey it's in you but still
new company right and it's a new company
I am standing on their side to defend
even if they screwed up big time made a
mistake but I still think that they
deserve a little bit of a benefit of
well doubt or credit for what they did
as an experiment because they were
experimenting and some of those
experiments did not end up very well but
as a company generally speaking I think
companies like Facebook will continue
defining our future in my opinion agreed
and not only do they deserve another
chance of course with with everything
but also think about all the benefits
that we've been able to reap we are
their product that's what we don't pay
for their service that's time to where
you're worried where your product so you
get the rights to the data which will
soon change with the we were just
talking to Dan gaily on the show from
founder of synapse AI making he's making
decentralized blockchain economies ai
economies really smart guy some probably
a great connection for Silicon Valley
Innovation Center but just the idea that
this general data and privacy rights is
it's gonna change a lot we're gonna go
from the from the the the vertical
ownership of data to these horizontal
marketplaces of data were Amazon sharing
their data to Facebook sharing Google's
sharing the ones that are left behind
are the source are and they're the ones
that aren't sharing that's right and the
could the consumers need to do their
best to identify the ones that are open
sourcing for example a lot of
Millennials a lot of Jenn's ears a lot
of people that are young they put their
money where the social activists are so
the ones that actually have some sort of
division within their company that
focuses on making the world better so
not only is it part of providing value
and getting value but also in terms of
what is that company doing to try and
make the world better I think most of
the trends are gonna move towards
something like what you know Bill and
Melinda Gates do with their foundation
um the more that people get the chance
to earn money the more that they try and
go and help with polio or with malaria
or with poverty around the world
trying to uplift these other people in
the world so it's good that you're I
mean this is again we're just totally on
the same vibe with trying to have this
more global conversation about about the
future of business in the future of
disruption getting people on the same
page how about we ask you about what's
going on with the kind of with
globalization in general because we have
the Middle East we have Asia we have
Africa we have South America Central
America Europe we have all these other
parts of the world that are advancing in
technology in in in similar ways as the
US and in different ways than the US and
so where where do we where do we go with
the global conversation about how to you
know how to eradicate things like war
and poverty and disease but also how to
collaborate with each other most
effectively what do you think about
globalization and I don't know how we're
moving forward I think it's a it's a
it's a great question
globalization has obviously benefited
some countries more than it did some
other countries right when you look at
the benefits of globalization you can
see that there were some countries in
the past like the United States I would
submit that has been one of the best
beneficiaries of globalized trend and
yet what is happening right now is that
those benefits are shifting away from
countries that used to like the u.s. who
used to benefit from it a lot toward
some other countries like China for
example right and now we get the new
rhetoric coming from the current
leadership in white house trying to
close that open trade because there are
lots of people in the United States who
feel fundamentally insecure about
globalization yeah a globalized trade
yeah simply because they are not
benefiting from that trade anymore well
at least they don't
feel that like they're benefiting if you
look at the growth of incomes you think
that's the reason that the Trump's and
the teals of the world are becoming more
nationalistic is because they're not
benefiting from the trades with well
they are certainly finding lots of voter
support right for those slogans yeah in
that rhetoric but do you because there
are tens of millions of people do you
think that with the political economy
though that that is the true is that
true or is that too defensive and
national are we benefiting more from
open the open trade and the
conversations and the trade with with
China to into further propel globalism I
personally tend to believe that yes even
though United States is not the main
beneficiary anymore from open trade
China probably is when you look at the
bilateral relationship between China and
the US yeah we certainly are running a
huge deficit right trade deficit in that
relationship so China is gaining more
than the u.s. is but just strictly
speaking in terms of trade but the if
but if you think the alternative
scenario where we stopped all the trade
between the two countries the US would
have suffered a lot from that as well
right so relatively speaking yeah the
u.s. is still gaining a lot from the
open trade right it's just that the
relative weight of those gains is kind
of changing it's in China's favor now
but does that mean that shutting it off
completely or are we just renegotiating
so that it's back to right yeah well
that's where it becomes really tricky
how do you renegotiate it to make it
more fair because the way how it would
look more fair from the US side of
course would look totally different from
China from the Chinese side right they
already said that you know they're not
gonna give up their national interest so
they will retaliate those two those
measures and so on so once you get into
a trade war most likely everybody will
end up losing from there because then
you get emotions being involved on both
sides you get countermeasure
and it's like in every war it's very
hard to find a war in history where one
side would be a clear winner and the
other side would be a cleaner CLE a
clear loser you get both sides usually
being really damaged with the war right
and and and then one of them would be a
more winner but still losing a lot from
where it was before right when you look
but this is what all wars are about and
the longer they last the more losing
both sides are from anymore including
trade wars so if this trade war becomes
a reality and if we get this war
continue for years and years then when
we will kind of wake up from that
nightmare we will see that the US will
have suffered a lot
China will probably suffer as well but
the world is not going to become any
better you know that's my personal
opinion on that that I don't think trade
wars are the right solution for making
trade more fair you need to find some
more subtle ways of you know fine-tuning
the future between different countries
agreed on that totally agreed on that I
I would love to have a more global
conversation about trade and about
prospering together rather than just
making decisions like we're gonna close
off our borders you're gonna close off
yours we're not gonna trade any more or
we're in our own self-interest
self-interest it's and also not healthy
these are your brothers and sisters
across the ocean no matter what you
think they are your brothers and sisters
not only are we 99.9 percent genetically
similar but also you don't need an alien
species to be found before you realize
that we're all together on this rock it
shouldn't take that long and it's a
human race now there are more reasons
for us to think as one entity than in
the past
but just just think about environment
for example right this is something
where we're all tied together right
together right and if we survive we will
survive together if we go down we will
probably go down together
we're not gonna have just one country
suffering from you know global warming
and other countries being fine no we
have to raise our consciousness to the
level when we will all think about each
other like you said like one huge family
it's kind of sounds a bit too naive I
guess but it's reality of our life that
things like climate or global prosperity
yeah it's another huge public good I
would say that comes out of global trade
we have to think about it as a product
of us as a humanity yes not just
nation-state exactly
Andre now let's ask you about what do
you think as we get to this perspective
and we get shifted towards this
direction what do you think about the
eight people that have about as much
wealth as the bottom four billion even
though you know the pinker argument is
right that everyone is collectively
coming up slowly it's true this gap you
know Ron and I always talk about how
it's the end of the middle class aside
yes so what do you think we should do
about this middle class are this
inequality that's going on how do we fix
it as a world well I I don't have any
kind of perfect solution for that
situation I totally agree with your
assessment Alan that it's a it's a
dangerous situation right it's a
dangerous situation not only because if
you people are becoming so rich that
their wealth can be compared to the rest
of you know population yeah but it's
also the fact that the rest of the
population is looking at that situation
and they become angry even though they
are becoming wealthier yeah yes that's
right
but it's not just an absolute growth in
wealth which is important here it's also
relative changes I make people really
angry if you can given that was really
important was with in McKinsey their
studies about the next 70 or so trillion
dollars in the next decade or so that's
going to be added to the global pie
what percentage of that is going to be
made by the eight people versus the
percentage that's me as the other four
Billy exactly well well here's another
reason another good reason why it's
important when you think about major
social upheavals like like social
revolutions that had happened in the
past about the reason when they happened
they didn't happen when those societies
were just declining in their wealth they
actually happened when societies were
growing and yet during that process of
growth there was this smaller group of
people who was becoming that were
becoming insanely rich and the others
were just growing well not so fast and
this is when those who were growing not
so fast they became really angry at
those elites that were controlling them
and this is when they they they rose
against and rebelled against that elite
so if we want to avoid these very
disruptive changes in societies we have
to be mindful of what this relative
growth and wealth can create among the
wider population and how they are gonna
react to this right so in order to avoid
major violent disruptions in the future
I think well both rich people have to
think about how to be more benevolent
with their wealth you know and I think
some of them are setting up amazing
examples yes of giving away their wealth
like you mentioned Bill and Melinda
Gates maximizing the efficacy of giving
away their wealth it's not right
not just giving away but actually taking
care of their wealth yeah right and
trying to alleviate some of the major
problems in Africa and elsewhere in the
world this is more fulfillment and
meaning does hiring 50 people to solve a
global problem do for you than buying a
30-odd exactly what gives you more
meaning good that's right that's right
so I think these people have a space
social responsibility before the rest of
society from which they actually
benefited right by building their wealth
nobody wants to deny of course their
talents and their their right to use
that wealth and yet in my opinion these
people have a huge personal
responsibility for the future
development of humankind and they have
to respond in kind to societies from
which they build that wealth right and
that's why I applaud a Mark Zuckerberg
when he announced that he's going to
going to spend like 99 percent of his
fortune the same way like Bill Gates
against it and I think these are amazing
examples that are being established by
the wealthiest people and they these
examples have to I think have to be used
by the other you know wealthy people how
to turn that wealth for the benefit of
humanity yeah especially because it came
from the piggybacking on all the people
that decided to pay you for your cousin
service that's right so ok how about the
question of what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world well I
think where we have an opportunity to
create the most beautiful thing in the
world is comes from inside of ourselves
rather than from outside and I I
personally believe that the way how we
can apply our inner world to outside in
my opinion is the like every time when
we see creativity being manifested by
people that's where beauty actually
comes from in my opinion right so every
time when you see in a new invention
being built
that's could be you know the most
beautiful thing in the world for me
personally I guess it's my family that's
you know my children are the most
beautiful creatures in the world and in
some ways I of course participated in
creating them even though I don't
attributed just to myself and my wife so
it's kind of that moment of turning
what's inside of you with the way that
you feel like you can bring your most
value to the world and actually
delivering that to the world that's kind
of I personally believe that this this
is our destiny as a humankind yeah used
to manifest our inner potential and
apply to the rest of the world that's
beautiful some of those things might be
really ugly like atomic bomb it's also
our manifestation it is our creative in
typically by some angry people that are
upset about the world other countries
and all that kind of stuff it's where
people that want to hurt other people
right across the world so it's a it's a
manifestation of the inner workings that
is yes not as healthy and violence
generally speaking it's also
manifestation of what of who we are
right
all of our hidden fears hatred
insecurities all of that and yet somehow
this is the most beautiful thing in the
world in my opinion
you know it's the way of how we are
manifesting ourselves we're taking what
is hidden inside of us and we're
applying that to the to the outside
world and this is how we're defining
this world changing this world and hey
maybe we will end up killing ourselves
which will be a tragic global mistake of
course for Humanity we will not do that
I hope we don't we will not destroy the
light of but even if that happens you
know even if that happens human beings
had a chance to manifest whatever they
had inside of themselves to the rest of
the world it will be very tragic of
course and I pray that it never happens
even to a smaller extent like
Wars wouldn't be happening right because
they're a huge waste of our energy yeah
and human lives even trade wars are
terrible yeah like to just discuss yes
but I think the most just to answer to
return to your question the most
beautiful thing in my opinion in the
world is the way how humans are capable
of manifesting themselves I love that I
love that all right how about are we
alone in the cosmos are we alone in
cosmos you're asking it's almost like a
philosophical questions it's not only
physical questions right we haven't had
officially speaking any any contact that
you know would be recognized socially or
politically as official contact with
other other lives I guess other
civilizations I personally tend to
believe that there are lots of other
dimensions that we just don't know about
that exist in parallel with our
existence and there are lots of weird
things that happen in our lives that can
be explained by the fact that were not
yet in touch with those dimensions but
there might be other worlds at least
intellectually I cannot rule that out
that there might be other dimensions
temporal dimensions but also a spatial
dimensions were all kinds of beings
might potentially exist yeah and yet we
as humans being as human beings are not
at this stage of our development where
we could incorporate that experience in
our current perception of ourselves and
perception of our reality this is why
there are lots of scientists who don't
believe in you know in those worlds
simply because you know it would be
sheer speculation for them
yeah and when and don't get me wrong
when I'm saying that I'm also kind of
speculating as well I just I would say
that I don't want to flat out deny the
possibility of other worlds existing in
parallel with our world as well
likewise Ron and I talk about that a lot
the world's outside of the 3d reality
that our meat puppets flesh vehicles
live within we we love talking about
that because we think that it's
something that is what do you think
yourself Ellen about that I don't know
but I'm very interested in talking about
it okay yeah for example I had a very
fascinating dream where this whole
entire studio got a big makeover change
Ron decided to like add tons of tons of
like television the quick the massive
cameras and audio systems and I woke up
and I walked downstairs and I was like
what is going on right now and so just
you know what is that a sign of what is
that is that just my brain being
creative and you know running a sandbox
simulation or is there something more to
that that was that goes on outside of
what we perceive to be reality what we
actually understand so we talk about
that a lot and the the next the next
question there's only two more the lot
of the set the second last question is
do you think we're in a computer
simulation right now
are you simulating me or I'm simulating
here or we are like any joint
civilization sort of like a matrix well
that's even more speculative question
all right well I think that human beings
do reproduce their cut have to reproduce
their consciousness all the time and in
that sense yes what is surrounding us
and what we feel about ourselves is the
product of our
life energy so in that regard I am
simulating this reality to the degree to
which my simulation overlaps with yours
we have a real world/road right so we
have a lots of conventions about what
real world is about because there is
some kind of reality out there right
that we have agreed to think about as a
black table table for example right or
water there are other things and yet
there are lots of things in my life that
don't overlap with yours right which I
am also using your language simulating
for myself I'm simulating your children
in your life because I don't know that
yes so those those artifacts I guess
those pieces of reality my reality they
are not the part of our convention and
yet they might be as real for me as the
other parts of the reality like your
birthplace in your life from 0 to 20
even mine to my convictions you know my
beliefs you know I might have all kinds
of crazy believes that you will not
share their yeah right because they're
not real for you but they might be
totally real for me and then I can start
acting on those beliefs right and this
is why we get a lot of things that we
don't agree with the Germans have a word
for it it's called une belt okay
yeah it's their their their sphere of
perception right and so huh to what
extent does my Moonville overlap with
yours and then then we have these
generic ways that we describe our
simulation or our reality whichever you
choose but that's good yes to that
degree there might be a little bit of
simulation right and when I die my
simulation at least in my physical body
stops you know and stop for all of us at
some point but then we still talk about
you after you die so then how long does
your consciousness live on yes and this
is the probably the most fascinating
question for science I I regret myself
personally that there are not enough
scientists means were interested in this
question yeah how much of consciousness
actually leave after our body there were
people that were
measuring it on the on a scale once
someone dies yeah and they said
something like a couple grams or
something get displaced at that point
lost the body weight yeah and so we
don't know exactly what that means but
it's also very you know there's not
enough people studying it yes and that's
what shows like this do we get more
people inspired to study it so please
keep sharing it keep going out there and
keep getting more people excited about
understand I think the biggest
inventions in science that is are going
to happen in the next few decades will
are not gonna come from physics they're
gonna come from learning energy inside
of ourselves yes you know the way how
our brain works with the rest of our
body works with the rest of the world
and how the functions of the brain can
actually be replicated and maybe
transferred if we can transfer the
activity of our brain then presumably we
can transfer our consciousness out of
our physical body into some kind of
other carrier and if that happens who
knows maybe humanity will be able to you
know we will not just humanity but we as
human beings will be able to sustain
ourselves existing in other types of
bodies not just physical existence and
maybe that's how humanity will transfer
itself from biological form to some kind
of when you form we're really excited
for that we just talked about that was a
little tiniest fun we were just talking
about trans human that's amazing all
right he actually his quote is that it's
the end of mammals well maybe it's the
end of biological life the exact size
right yeah yeah hopefully it's not like
a total end of it is just a next step
out yeah next kill ourselves as a result
of that the next evolution how about as
a last question is what is one thing
that you believe to be true that nobody
else believes to be true wow that goes
were like really deep into the personal
convictions right you would need to
simultaneously believe in something so
strongly and at the same time think that
everybody else would not believe in that
wow that's a very tricky question he's
in his answers are so diplomatic I just
I'm just trying to think about am I so
original in my life that I could have at
least one belief that would be so
different from everybody else think
about the importance of it related to
like Bruno and Copernicus and Galileo
right people that decided that were they
were the only ones that thought that the
earth actually revolved around the star
and not the and not the other way and
then furthermore as think about all
think about all the other people that
are deemed to be crazy by society
because they're the only ones that think
in a certain way and then eventually
they're the right ones and so that's why
this question is kind of the one verse
99 thing right if you're the black sheep
what is it that you hold in your head
and what can you voice to the world
about that black sheep thought that we
can try and share that's interesting
well I guess I have lots of beliefs
about myself about the capabilities of
my company but these are all personal
beliefs right here people don't share
them simply because they don't know me
right that's that's why I would be very
unique in holding those beliefs your
question is more about believes that you
know motivated Copernicus to you know to
stand up against the church right
because he was so confident about earth
not being the center of the world right
but there's you know Sun and everything
else in that regard you know there are
lots of things that have already been
discovered of course I guess where I as
a scientist I still consider myself to
be a scientist where I would stand more
separate from the rest of scientific
community would be my beliefs about
about humans being much more than what
we know about them right now that there
are multiple dimensions that I mentioned
to you before that's good
where I think most of the inventions
will be coming from in the future we're
not going to be going and studying
natural physics as the source of major
revelations in my opinion I think it
will be our inner world yeah that will
be discovered being intricately
connected with physical world outside
anxiety so in order to learn about the
rest of the world we have to go inside
of ourselves correct
maybe observe and meditate introspection
Ananda was on earth so he said that
inner management is the key to
enlightenment and is the key to peace
and is the key to yes all these things
that we're talking about globalization
and AI and economics political theory
all this stuff he said the meditation
and inner management is the key to all
of those yes and we found that to be so
fascinating the truth so you are right
and I like that one that you bring up is
that this whole inner workings
I'm really feeling our heartbeat that
hundred thousand times a day to really
feel the way that you're what you put in
your mouth is what actually powers the
body all these cool things there is
that's kind of what but then again I'm
not sure how different I am from lots of
your guests who are already thinking
about this am I like 1% I do think that
it's uh you're in the minority of people
that think that the next body
significant bodies of research are gonna
actually come from understanding within
I think you are okay so you know we
covered a lot about the future business
about disruptive technologies about your
background Silicon Valley Innovation
Center this has been an amazing
conversation alright great thank you
very much Alan thank you thank you we
would like to say do check out silken
Silicon Valley dot Center please check
them out online get a better
understanding of kind of what they do
and the importance of that so thanks for
tuning in everyone thanks for enjoying
the content and please feel free to
comment or
the streams if you had a good time like
comment subscribe do share the content
with other people also if you guys
really found the content useful become
patrons we've had two people become
patrons in just the last couple of hours
today it's been really great thank you
everyone for doing that I'm big shout
out to the Mike harden family office
over at big rock big shout out to Jordan
rain as well shout out to our producer
and director around Vargas thanks
everyone for tuning in we'll have some
more great content for you tomorrow with
Joshua Kaufman as well as a Jared Faison
so tune in tomorrow they'll be those
will be great shows and thank you very
much see you next time thank you
[Music]
[Music]